rising sea levels caused by global
warming will have ominous and
far-reaching consequences floods are
increasingly likely outside Amsterdam
airplanes land on runways that are three
metres below sea level and sinking in
fact more than half of the Netherlands
sits below sea level so the Dutch
government is taking steps to climate
proof the country for the next 200 years
this nondescript field in the North vard
region of Holland is actually ground
zero for the coming war against rising
water and climate change in this part of
the country the government is spending
some two billion dollars to take
farmland and turn it into the river the
dikes you see in the distance are going
to be lowered and in places removed so
that the river Beyond can flow in
flooding this farmland and relieving
pressure downstream blowing the river by
some three feet the Dutch are masters of
water management it even centuries of
experience diverting pumping and
blocking water can't prevent every
calamity in 1953 a killer storm flooded
hundreds of square miles and left more
than 1,800 people dead
the disaster assured in a new era of
fortification colossal storm surge
barriers were built during high tides
and severe storms the barrier gates are
closed
keeping inland areas safe from the
violence of the North Sea to the Dutch
rising seas are nothing new for
millennia sea levels have been inching
technically millimetre in upwards but
recently the rise has accelerated thanks
to global warming even in well fortified
countries like the Netherlands that
change is cause for alarm
in September the government formed delta
committee a task force set up to avert a
Katrina scale disaster in the future to
do so the Delta Committee recommends
aggressive steps they want to push the
coastline outward by as much as four
kilometers they want huge new storm
surge barriers bolstered levees and
closed off tidal rivers the Rhine is
especially worrisome it flows freely in
and out of Rotterdam which makes the
port city especially vulnerable to
flooding even floatable residential
complexes are being considered these
coastal protection techniques serve as a
model for low-lying cities around the
world
because the water is coming in to
Copenhagen Los Angeles Manila London New
York San Francisco Tokyo and the Dutch
water masters want to make sure that
their country stays dry